Do you advocate for more of a whole food plant based eating especially for cancer survivors like me I followed Chris works program and that's the approach he takes so curious what your thoughts are.
So always a whole food diet is best so whole food is eating the whole thing
and eating foods that we were in the best way that God created us to eat those foods.
So that's a whole food diet. Plant based eating is that the best thing to do for cancer or someone to prevent future cancer coming up?
No not always so everybody's different so can a plant based diet be the right thing to do for a person if they have cancer?
Yes it can be can a plant based diet be the wrong diet for a person with cancer?
Yes it can be everybody's different and sources of cancer's growth can change over time.
So a person's on a plant based diet and their cancer goes into remission and they're doing really well and then the cancer comes back so they go they stay they've been on this plant based diet what's the deal?
The cancer has found another fuel source so you need to change your diet if you can't figure that out through testing and we do an physiology testing to figure that out.
But if you don't have that available to you you have to just change your diet so cancer is constantly trying to find a fuel source in order to grow.
So if it's not if you know a plant based diet is can be through a plant based diet you're still getting different proteins you're still getting amino acids through that and you're still getting glucose.
So lots of times that based diet with cancer involves juicy which could be high in level increasing levels of glucose and if glucose is your main source of that fuel for that cancer that can be very much the wrong diet to be on.
So everybody's different is my answer so I don't say that every cancer patient should do this or that.
Now there are some things that you could make generalities about with cancer but not everything so no I don't advocate for a plant based eating for everybody and I don't another diet that's coming is a ketogenic diet for cancer patients should all there's there's books written about every cancer patients should be out of ketogenic diet.
And my answer to that is no that's not right everybody is different would a ketogenic diet be good for me maybe but maybe it's going to be the very wrong thing for you.
ketogenic diet is going to be obviously much higher in animal proteins and if your cancer is fed off of glutamine then it's probably not the right diet for you at this time.
So everybody is different another cancer diet that has been covered is a is a raw food diet is that good for everybody no it's not so typically a raw food diet is going to include obviously raw whole foods like this person is asking this question and you see which is going to be higher in glucose also you got to think of a raw food diet.
It's going to be more appropriate the younger a person is because they're going to be producing enough digestive enzymes to deal with raw food not cooked food which takes a lot more pancreatic enzymes to break down that if you are you know eating your food that's more cooked.
An example would be if a person has really bad gut issues you put them on more of a gaps type diet gaps is is food that's really broken down maybe they're only eating super they're only eating bone broth that we would use bone broth with cancer patients that uses an example that's all they can tolerate at this time even a young person.
So everybody's different I don't take a one way approach to cancer and I don't even take a one way approach to that specific person because that diet for that person can change so we might have them on a on a whole food plant based diet for a period of time and we switch them to be more of a carnivore for a period of time.
So you have to be willing to change things up because cancer is always changing and always trying to fight a fuel source so that worked for you.
At that time that's great this but just be aware that it might not always work for you.
And what worked for you be careful not to say to tell everybody that you just need to do this because this worked for me because it doesn't work for everybody nothing is going to work for everybody.